Bu Mira. Mahallenin dar bir sokağında, üçüncü kattaki evde oturuyor.
O sabah perdesini açtı ve sokağı sular altında buldu.
Gece yağın şiddetli yağmur, alt sokakları tamamen doldurmuştu.
Belediye ekipleri, çamurla kaplanan yolu temizlemeye çoktan başlamıştı.
Komşular kapılarının önünde durmuş, suyun bıraktığı hasara bakıyordu.
Mira dışarı çıktı ve fark etti. Kimse tek başına değildi.
İnsanlar bazı ihtiyaçlarını yaşanları boyunca tek başlarına karşılayamayabilir.
Afetler ve ekonomik güçlükler karşısında başkalarının desteğine ihtiyaç duyarlar.
İşte böyle günlerde yardımlaşma ve dayanışmanın önemi daha iyi anlaşılır.
Karşı komşusu yaşlı bir çiftin evinin alt katını su basmıştı.
Üç komşu geldi ve eşyaları hep birlikte üst kata taşıdı.
Biraz öte de başkaları yiyecek ve giyecekleri kolilere yerleştiriyordu.
Yardımlaşma, ihtiyacı olan kişilere maddi veya manevi destek vermektir.
Dayanışma ise, ortak amaç çevresinde birleşenlerin birbirine güç vermesidir.
Bu iki değer toplumdaki insanları birbirine yakınlaştırır.
Öğleye doğru okulun spor salonu geçici bir yardım merkezine dönüştü.
Gönüllüler gelen malzemeleri türlerine göre ayırıp diziyordu.
Bir grup kolileri taşırken, diğeri ihtiyaç listesini kontrol ediyordu.
Mira'nın görevi, kolilerin üstüne içindekini büyük harflerle yazmaktı.
Düzenli çalışabilmek için iş bölümü yapılır.
Herkes bir görev üst denir.
Bir işi birlikte gerçekleştirmeye iş birliği denir.
Bilgi, emek ve imkanlar birleşince sorunlar çok daha hızlı çözülür.
Ertesi sabah, mahalleye yelekli ekipler geldi ve hemen çalışmaya başladı.
Afat görevleri, zarar gören binaları tek tek kontrol etti.
Türk Kızılay, sokağın başına kurulup sıcak yemek dağıtmaya başladı.
Belediye ekipleri sokakları temizledi ve geçici barınma alanları hazırladı.
Kamukurumları, belediyeler ve sivil koplum kuruluşları da toplum için çalışır.
O akşam Mira, dedesine gün boyunca gördüklerini anlattı.
Dedesi bunun çok eski bir geleneğimiz olduğunu söyledi.
Osmanlı döneminde sokak köşelerinde sadaka taşları bulunurdu.
İmkanı olan taşın oyuna parasını bırakır, ihtiyacı olan görünmeden alırdı.
Böylece yardım, ihtiyaç sahibinin onuru korunarak yapılırdı.
Dedesi sonra milli mücadele yıllarındaki büyük dayanışmayı anlattı.
Tekalifi milliye emirleriyle, halk yiyeceğini ve taşıtını ordusuyla paylaştı.
Ertesi hafta okulun girişinde karşılanmamış ihtiyaçların yazıldığı bir pano hazırlandı.
Katkı sağlamak için büyük imkanlara sahip olmak gerekmez.
Bir kişi kan bağışında bulunabilir, gönüllüler sokak hayvanlarını besleyebilir.
Öğrenciler kitaplarını paylaşabilir, bir mahalle birlikte fidan dikebilir.
Mira ve arkadaşları kendi dayanışma projelerini kurumaya karar verdi.
Önce ihtiyacı belirlediler, kitapları sudan zarar gören öğrenciler.
Sonra bir kitap kampanyası planlayıp aralarında görev dağılımı yaptılar.
Okul yönetimi ve muhtarlıkla iş birliği kurdular.
Toplanan malzemeler kontrol edilip ihtiyaç sahibi öğrencilere ulaştırıldı.
Planlı hareket etmek, yardımın amacına ulaşmasını sağlar.
Haftalar geçti ve mahalle yeniden eski haline döndü.
Komşular ortak alanda birlikte fidan dikip çevreyi temizledi.
Dayanışma sayesinde ihtiyaçlar karşılanır, güçlükler daha kolay yaşılır.
İnsanlar arasındaki güven, empati ve sosyal bağlar güçlenir.
Böylece toplumda birlik, beraberlik ve huzur ortamı gelişir.
Mira o dar sokağa bir kez daha baktı.
Paylaşılan her imkan ve verilen her emek toplumsal birliği güçlendirir.
Paylaştıkça çoğalır, dayanıştıkça güçleniriz.
Peki sen, çevrende hangi ihtiyaç için bir proje hazırlayabilirsin?
Cevaplarınızı yorumlara bekliyoruz.
Dayanışmayla kalın, birlikte güçlü kalın.